but we are going to turn now to politics
who is Simply the Best in that category
and does love have anything to do with
it we're talking about the presidential
campaign of Governor Ron DeSantis of
Florida it is now official he opened his
Run for the White House with a Twitter
video last night that part pretty
traditional but it was followed by an
online event with Twitter CEO Elon Musk
and that was plagued by technical issues
it led to mockery from other candidates
including President Biden and no
surprise here former president Donald
Trump Robert Costa is in Miami covering
the campaign for us uh you know it was
billed as a great American comeback
those are the words of Ron DeSantis and
you can set your clock by it but you
could not set your clock by that Twitter
event good morning
Good morning Tony some DeSantis allies
they were disappointed by the technical
glitches but they say the governor will
be plowing ahead underscoring his
conservative credentials and all this
scrutiny and the criticism it is a
reminder of just how rough the waters
are going to be in this campaign
I'm Ron DeSantis and I'm running for
president to lead our Great American
comeback Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
posted a video making it official but
his launch with Elon Musk on Twitter
didn't go as smoothly
just a massive number of people online
so it's a service restraining somewhere
it was marked by technical difficulties
when the site kept crashing so I think
we're back online here and after a
20-minute delay if you nominate me you
can set your clock to January 20th 2025
at High Noon because on the west side of
the U.S Capitol I will be taking the
oath of office as the 47th president of
the United States it did break the
Twitter space and so we're really
excited with the enthusiasm his Rivals
were quick to pounce on Truth social
former president Trump called the launch
a disaster and President Biden tweeted a
link to his fundraising site noting this
link works on Twitter a spokesman for
the campaign said DeSantis literally
busted up the internet Washington is
next claiming he raised more than one
million dollars in the first hour but
DeSantis has a lot of ground to make up
in a new poll Trump is dominating the
Republican field with 53 percent support
from likely GOP Primary voters DeSantis
trails with 26 percent DeSantis was
saved by the endorsement of President
Trump the Trump campaign also attacked
DeSantis in new ads showing how DeSantis
previously supported the former
president isn't it time DeSantis
remembers how he got to where he is
other candidates in the crowded GOP
field took on DeSantis one saying he is
imitating his former supporter Turner
rival the way he speaks the way his hand
gestures are the fact that he's moved
his policies all of it's copying Trump
DeSantis advisors say many Republicans
like Trump but are also craving a
republican alternative a conservative
who can really win the nomination and be
from a new generation but the spotlight
only gets brighter from here and those
Trump attacks will likely pick up speed
Tony
yeah and Governor DeSantis taking a shot
at Donald Trump saying governing is not
about entertainment it's about results
we'll see what the voters think Bob
thank you very much